The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
TROY VAN VOORHIS: All right,
well, good morning, everyone.
I'm not Bob Field, but I'm Troy.
Nice to see everyone.
So I'm here.
We're going to spend the
next couple of lectures
talking about electronic
structure theory.
And at this point, I'll
give you the big reveal,
which is that at this point,
you have already encountered
virtually every problem
that you can solve by hand
in electronic structure theory.
So there's a handful
of other things
you could do if you
really, like, knew
your hypergeometric functions
and some things like this,
but basically, every
electronic structure problem
that you can solve by hand
you've already encountered.
And so if chemistry
relied on us being
able to solve things by hand,
we wouldn't get very far.
We'd be pretty limited
in what we could do.
So we end up using the fact
that we have computers.
And computers are far more good
at doing tedious repetitive
things that human beings are.
They don't complain at all.
And so we can use computers
to do fairly neat things.
So I'll show you just a
couple of quick pictures here
of things that we can do.
So if you open up
any research paper
these days, even if it's
just synthesis-- you know,
we made this catalyst.
We did this thing, whatever.
There's always some part
of it where they said,
well, we did a
calculation, and this is
what the structure looks like.
Or this is what the
orbitals look like
or something like this.
So this was actually
a calculation.
We are computational
chemists, I guess.
I'll use this screen over here.
Is this the one that you're--
or you're filming this one.
This one?
All right. so I'll film
this one-- go to this one.
Breaking the fourth wall there.
So this is the
picture of the HOMO,
the reactive orbital
water-splitting catalyst
that we computed.
So you can see that
there's 50, 60 atoms here,
probably several
hundred electrons.
We did not do this by hand.
We didn't draw the
surfaces by hand.
The computer did
all of this for us.
And you can also do things
like look at chemical reactions
and run dynamics.
So we can do--
there we go.
So you can run
dynamics of molecules.
So this is a particular
molecule in solution.
And we can use the
electronic energy
in order to govern the
dynamics of the molecule.
And the computer
can actually predict
for us whether this
molecule is going to react,
what it's going to
do, how it's going
to behave in one
solution, say, versus
another or at one particular
temperature versus another,
those kinds of things.
And all of these, again,
are based off of the idea
that we can use computers
to solve problems
in electronic structure, or
at least approximately solve
problems we couldn't do by hand.
And so what the goal over
the next couple lectures
is for us to learn
enough of the basics
so that you can do
some calculations
like this yourselves and then
see what you can do with that.
So now I will switch over.
You'll find where the
other differences, which
is that I don't like the
feeling of chalk on my fingers,
so I use my iPad
as a chalkboard.
So the rest of this
will all be on the iPad.
There we go.
So for those of
you who want to--
you may not have
gotten in this time.
But I've literally
posted what I'm
going to be writing on here,
these blank notes, online.
You can download them,
print them off, if you want.
If you have an
iPad or a computer,
and you like to
take notes on that,
you can download them
to your iPad or computer
and take notes that way.
But I find it's good because
there are some things that
take a long time for me
to write at the board
and that it would take
a long time for you
to write in your notes.
And we can just have them
written down in advance.
So the starting point
for all of these things
that you can do on a computer
for electronic structure
theory, we start with
the Born-Oppenheimer
approximations.
So the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation
was the idea that because
the nuclei are very heavy,
you can clamp their positions
down to some particular values.
So in this particular case
here, in this equation,
I have it such that big R here
are the nuclear positions.
So there's going to be more
than one nucleus generally.
So there's going
to be R1, R2, R3.
All those crammed together,
I'm just going to denote big R
And that's where the nuclei are.
And so in Born-Oppenheimer
approximation,
we clamp the nuclei down.
And then what we're left
with is the electrons.
The electrons whiz around.
They move in the field
dictated by those nuclei.
So we have a
Schrodinger equation
that describes the
motion of the electrons
in the presence of the nuclei.
And so here I'm using the lower
case letters, lowercase r.
So they'll be, again, many
electrons, so r1, r2, r3, so on
and so forth.
And it's the electrons that are
really doing all the dirty work
in this equation.
They're the ones that
are moving around.
I've clamped the nuclei down.
They're just parameters
in this equation.
And so what I have is I
have an electronic wave
function that describes the
distribution of electrons.
I have an electronic
Hamiltonian that governs
the motion of the electrons.
Then I have an electronic
energy after I've solved
this Schrodinger equation.
And the nice thing about
this is that for an arbitrary
number of electrons and an
arbitrary number of nuclei,
I can in one line,
in about 10 seconds,
write down the Hamiltonian.
So the Hamiltonian is
pretty easy to write down.
I've even written it right here.
So I did use the cheat
of using atomic units.
So the reason there's no H
bars or mass of the electrons
or any of that
appearing in here is
because I chose atomic units.
But then the ingredients
of my Hamiltonian
are all pretty well-defined.
So I'll have some
kinetic energy.
And that kinetic energy will
just be for the electrons
because the nuclei are fixed.
I'll have an electron-electron
repulsion term.
So of course, the
electrons repel each other.
I'll have an electron
nuclear attraction term
because the nuclei are
fixed in positions,
and the electrons feel
a potential due to that.
And then I have a
nuclear repulsion term.
And in this case, because
the nuclei are fixed,
that nuclear repulsion
is just a number
because I know where
all my nuclei are.
They have some particular
repulsion energy.
That's just some number that I
add onto my Hamiltonian there.
But if I put all
those things together,
I get the Hamiltonian.
So I can write down
the Hamiltonian
without too much difficulty.
But of course, the
interesting thing
here is this Hamiltonian depends
on these nuclear positions.
So I have to know what--
depending on where
the nuclei are,
I'm parametrically
changing this Hamiltonian.
That changes H, and it also
changes the eigenvalue,
the electronic eigenvalue
E. And so there's
an obvious question
of, well, what
is this electronic eigenvalue?
It turns out to be a
very important thing.
We will typically call this
thing a potential energy
surface.
And it turns out to
govern a whole host
of chemical phenomena.
So the first thing
that it could generate
that we can look at--
we've already actually seen
potential energy surfaces.
So on the left-hand side
here, I have the picture
from the case of H2-plus.
So here we had the energy
of the sigma orbital.
And as a function of
R, it forms some bonds.
So as we made R shorter, the
sigma orbital formed a bond.
Then we had also this
sigma star orbital
as a function of R. When we
brought the atoms together,
in that one there was no
bond, no swarming energy.
It just went straight up.
So we've got two
of these things,
and I should label my axes.
So what I'm plotting
here is the energy
as a function of
the bond distance R.
So this was our first
example of a potential energy
surface, the electronic
energy as a function of R.
And we see that it taught
us about the bond, the bond
strength, so forth.
There's one other thing that
this picture reminds me of,
and that's that for
the same problem here,
I actually had two different
potential energy surfaces.
I have the sigma potential
energy surface and sigma star.
And that's because I left
something out in my Schrodinger
equation up here.
There's, of course, an index.
I have different eigenfunctions
of the Schrodinger equation.
So I have an
electronic Hamiltonian.
It'll have many
different eigenfunctions.
So I have an index n for
those eigenfunctions.
And each of those eigenfunctions
will have a different energy.
And each of those energies is
a different potential energy
surface.
So the sigma state was
the lowest solution.
The sigma start state was
the next lowest solution.
They had different
potential surfaces.
But I will often not refer
to potential energy surfaces
plural but instead to potential
energy surface singular
because most chemistry occurs
on the lowest potential energy
surface.
So it involves just the lowest
potential energy surface.
And the reason for that is
because electronic energies
tend to be very big
in chemical terms.
So the difference between
sigma and sigma star
is several EV, typically.
And chemical reactions
on that same scale
are usually tenths
or hundreds of an EV.
So the chemical reaction energy
might be somewhere way down
here, way way, way below
the amount of energy
you would need to get all
the way up to sigma star.
And so the sigma star,
potential energy surface
is just irrelevant.
It's there, but it doesn't
participate in the reactions
at all.
So in most cases, knowing about
the lowest potential energy
surface gets you
most of chemistry.
But then we can also,
sort of, schematically
talk about how these potential
energy surfaces will look
for a more complicated example.
So let's say I had the
water molecule, HOH.
So this is a more general case.
We have at least two
coordinates here, R1 and R2.
There's also going
to be an angle,
but I can't really
plot three-dimensional
hypersurfaces, even
with my computer.
So I'll stick with two.
There's a third
coordinate there,
which is theta, which I'm not
going to play around with.
But we'll play around
with just R1 and R2.
So I can change
individually the OH bond
lengths in this molecule.
So then this is going
to give me the energy
as a function of R1 and R2.
So it'll be a surface.
So it's a function
of two variables.
That's a surface.
And that surface might look
like what I have plotted there,
where it would have various
peaks and valleys on it.
The very, very lowest valley,
the very lowest minimum,
just like we found for
H2, that lowest minimum
was the equilibrium bond--
bonding configuration.
So for this two-dimensional
potential surface,
that lowest minimum's
going to be the equilibrium
configuration.
But there's also the
possibility of other minima
on this potential
energy surface.
Those would be metastable
intermediates, things
that you could get
trapped in, things
that would live for a while,
but eventually go down
towards the lowest minimum.
Then there'd also be
reaction barriers.
So these are the things that
we learned about governing
how fast things convert
from these metastable states
into the most stable states.
So that's what you would get if
you had just two coordinates.
And so then you can sort of
try to generalize in your head,
well, what if we had 3,
4, 5, 6, 127, 368, lots
and lots of coordinates?
In some many dimensional
space, it would still
have the same qualities.
There'd be minima and
barriers and so forth.
And we would get those out
of the Schrodinger equation,
the electronic
Schrodinger equation.
And so that is the
electronic structure problem.
How do we accurately solve
for the electronic eigenvalue
and the electronic wave function
for an arbitrary molecule?
And the key word
here is accurately.
I didn't just say
how can we solve
for electronic energy and
the electronic wave function
because, in general here,
exact solutions are impossible.
And I don't mean
impossible for 5.61.
I mean impossible for
humans or computers.
So in general, electronic
structure theorists
love approximations.
We love to make approximations
because that's the only way
that you can make progress.
And so what we're going to learn
about today and next Monday
are the, sort of, different
categories of approximations
that we make and what the
pluses and minuses of those are.
So I'll pause there and see
if anybody has any questions.
All right, so
we'll move on then.
So we have an out--
so there is actually an
outline of how different
modern electronic structure
methods make approximations.
And these follow the
same kinds of steps
that you would use in a
molecular orbital calculation.
So the first thing
that you typically
had to do in these
calculations was
to choose a set of
basis functions.
So you had to choose like
1s function over here
or 1s function over there
or a 2s function or 2p.
You had to choose some
set of atomic orbitals
that you're going to use
as the starting point
of your calculation.
Then you made linear
combinations of those things
to get better functions.
And so then after you'd
chosen that basis,
you had to build some matrices.
Then you had to solve
the eigenvalues problem
for that matrix.
Then you had to pick out which
orbitals you were actually
going to occupy.
Those were the next few steps.
And then finally, you had
to compute the energy.
Now, that's already kind
of a detailed outline.
If it seemed like
we had to understand
the nuances of every
one of those five steps,
we'd be kind of--
well, you can do that.
It would be an entire
course unto itself.
And that's not what
we're going to be doing.
The reason that we can avoid
going over every single nuance
is twofold.
So first, we can avoid, more
or less, steps two through four
because they're
done automatically.
So once you have chosen your
basis that you want to use,
the computer knows
how to build matrices.
It knows how to diagonalize
matrices and find eigenvalues.
It knows how to pick out
which orbitals to occupy.
It knows how to do
all of those things
without you telling
it to do anything.
You don't really have
to change anything.
So the only things you
have to worry about
are choosing a
good basis and then
also telling the computer a
good way to compute the energy.
The other reason that we can
actually do something useful
here is because using
a computer to solve
an electronic
structure problem is
much like using an NMR to
get a spectrum of a compound.
I doubt that
anybody in this room
could build their
own functioning NMR.
I know generally the
principles of how an NMR works.
But building from
the ground up-- oh,
so we do have any takers?
Anybody able to
build and NMR, huh?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
TROY VAN VOORHIS:
From the ground up.
I'm betting-- no.
See?
You have to actually, like,
make your own superconducting
magnet.
You've got-- from the
ground up, actually
building your own NMR would
be very, very difficult.
But that doesn't
preclude you from knowing
how to use an NMR
because you know,
OK, well, this piece is-- this
dial is roughly doing this,
so I change this over here.
I shim this.
That's how I make the NMR work.
It's the same thing with
electronic structure code.
You need to understand a little
bit of how they work in order
to use them effectively.
But you don't have to understand
every single line of code that
went into building
it, which is good
because there's several
hundred thousand lines of codes
in many of these electronic
structure packages.
So we're going to try to
understand the principles that
go into this so that
we know how to be
good users of
computational tools.
And we can actually,
then, organize.
So roughly speaking, we'll
be focusing on step one today
and step five next Monday.
But we can organize
these approximations
on a sort of
two-dimensional plot, which
just sort of summarizes
the whole idea of what
we're going to be getting at.
So the idea here
is that on one axis
we have the step
one thing, which
is the basis, the
atomic orbital basis.
Then we can organize those
basis, those choices of basis,
from, roughly speaking, on the
left hand, we have bad choices.
And on the right hand,
we have good choices.
Now, you might say, well, why
would we even include choices
if we know they're bad?
Because the bad ones also
happen to be the fast basis.
And the good ones
tend to be slow.
And so it's a time trade-off.
So you have a lot
of time, you might
choose a really good basis.
If you have not a
lot of time, you
might choose not
a very good one.
And then we can do the
same thing with the energy.
We have different choices of
how we compute the energy.
And we can roughly arrange those
from bad choices to good ones.
But again, these bad
choices are fast,
and the good ones are slow.
And so the general
thing that we want
is we want to get up here into
the upper right-hand corner,
where the exact answer is.
Somewhere up there, with a very
good energy and a very good
basis, we're going to
get the exact or nearly
the exact answer.
So that's where we want to get.
But moving from the lower
left to the upper right.
Every time we move
in that direction
we're making the calculation
slower and slower and slower
and slower and slower.
Until eventually we
just lose patience.
And so then we cut
it off and say,
all right, this is as
far as I'm willing to go.
What's the best
answer I can get?
What's the most best-cost
benefit analysis I can do?
And so in terms of
being good users
of electronic
computational chemistry,
it's about knowing,
OK, well, if I've only
got three hours for
this calculation to run
or two days or however long
I'm willing to let the computer
run on this, what's the
best combination of a basis
and an energy to get me a decent
result in that kind of time?
So questions about
that before I move on?
OK, so we'll focus on choosing
an atomic orbital basis.
So we already have chosen an
atomic orbital basis before.
So when we did H2-plus, which
is, sort of, a standard problem
that you can actually
solve by hand if you choose
the right basis, when
we did that calculation,
we chose to have an
atomic orbital on A,
the 1s function on A, and the
atomic orbital on B, 1s on B.
And those two things
together formed our basis.
So we wrote our
molecular orbitals
as linear combinations
of those two functions.
We got sigma and sigma star out.
And we were able to
work out the energies.
Now, this type of basis
is a useful basis.
And it has a name, and it's
called a minimal basis.
And it's minimal because you
could not possibly do less.
So if you want to form a
bond between two atoms,
you need at least one
function on each atom.
If you had only one
function, period,
you couldn't really form a bond.
So it's as low as you can
go, can't go lower than this.
Now, you could think
about the possibility
of adding additional functions.
So I could add in, say,
the 2s function on A,
the 2s function on B,
dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
I could come up
with various things.
Now, you might ask, why
would I want to do this?
And there's a very
good reason for doing
this, which is one
of the principles
that we need to learn in
constructing basis functions,
choosing our basis, which is
that adding basis functions
always improves the calculation.
So even though I think
that adding 2s A and 2s B,
why would those be important?
I can't really say.
Adding basis functions
always make things better.
And the reason for
that is because we were
doing a variation calculation.
We're trying to approximate the
lowest energy of the system.
And just choosing the 1s A and
1s B functions doesn't give you
the lowest energy.
It may be close,
but it's not exact.
So then by adding
the 2s functions,
the result could get
better by adding a little--
by making C3 and C4
not quite 0 here,
maybe the answer gets
a little bit better.
Maybe it doesn't, but
it can't get worse
because the calculation could
always choose C3 and C4 0.
So adding basis
functions always makes
things either better, or at
least not worse than they were.
And so what you'll
find is that when
we're talking about AO
basis, choosing an AO basis,
we're going to be
choosing bases that
are much bigger than your
chemical intuition would
suggest.
So for H2, I think,
oh, 1s A, 1s B,
that should more or
less describe things.
And if I was doing things by
hand, that's what I would do.
But if the computer's
doing the work,
well, no skin off my
nose if this computer
wastes some time doing some
2s or 3s or 4s intervals.
I'll let the computer
do that, as long
as it gives me a better answer.
So the bases we have will be
much bigger because of this.
But the other thing
I want to note
is that when I talk
about these 1s functions,
you probably all
have in your head--
you know what 1s
functions look like.
They look like e to
the minus a times r.
So they just look like
exponential decay functions.
Turns out that for
practical reasons,
these are inconvenient
things to use on a computer.
And that is because integrals
involving exponentials
are not analytic in three
dimensions primarily because
of the cusp that
occurs at r equal 0.
So if you multiply two of
these things times each other
and try to do an integral,
you have a cusp over here
and a cusp over here.
And the integral is
just not something
that can be worked out.
And so when the going gets
tough, the tough get empirical.
And so instead of using these
exponential functions, what we
use in practice are Gaussians.
So Gaussians are things
instead of looking
at like e to the minus ar,
they look like e to the minus
alpha r squared.
So if I was to plot a
Gaussian here on the same axes
and choose the alpha
value appropriately,
I could get a Gaussian
that might look like that.
So it would be similar to
that actual 1s function.
But particularly
near the origin,
where it doesn't have a cusp,
and particularly in the tails,
where e to the minus alpha r
squared decays very quickly,
they don't actually
look that similar.
So whole reason
to do this is not
that we have some
physical reason
to think that Gaussians
describe atoms is better
than hydrogenic functions.
They don't.
It's just that we
can do the integrals.
There's easy integrals here.
And if we really do want
a hydrogen-like function,
we can get that
by just including
more than one Gaussian.
So one Gaussian doesn't look
very much like an exponential.
But if I take two Gaussians
and choose their exponents
and their coefficients
appropriately,
I can make a linear
combination of two Gaussians.
So this was the one
Gaussian result.
With two Gaussians I
could make something
that might look like that.
And with three
Gaussians I might be
able do something
that would look like--
and then four Gaussians and five
Gaussians and six Gaussians.
But it's clear,
then, that by using
a large number of Gaussians,
I can get whatever
I want just by brute force.
And so those are the two
things about building basis,
choosing basis, AO bases.
And at this point,
you should start
to feel a little bit
intimidated because I've
said that for atoms you're
going to need more basis
functions than you
thought just to try to get
a variation a lower energy.
And those basis functions are
likely to be constructed out
of Gaussians, of which you'll
need a bunch of Gaussians
to even really approximate
one hydrogen-like orbital.
So you're going to have lots
and lots and lots of Gaussians
on every atom.
And you're going to choose the
exponents of every single one
of those Gaussians yourself.
And that would be just
horrible to have to do.
And the thing that
comes to our rescue
is a thing that's
known as a basis set.
So a basis set is constructed
in the following way.
A graduate student, probably
long before you were bored,
spent years of their life
going through and figuring out,
OK, for carbon, what
is a good combination
of Gaussian exponents?
OK, they're 113.6
74.2, 11.3, and 1.6.
They wrote that down.
They said, OK,
now, for nitrogen,
what are a good set
of Gaussian exponents?
And then they went
through, and they
did this for every
element, or at least many,
many, many elements
in the periodic table.
Then they wrote a paper
that said here is--
I did it.
So I'm going to say here
is the Troy basis set.
And the Troy basis
means when you
say you're doing the
Troy basis set means
you're using those
exponents that I wrote down
for carbon or for nitrogen
or for oxygen or for fluorine
or for hydrogen. And
it's all predefined.
It's all laid out.
And if I was really
diligent, it's
laid out for every element
in the periodic table.
If I was less
diligent, maybe it's
only the first two rows
or something like that.
But the result is that
all you have to say
is I want the Troy
basis set because Troy
makes really good basic sets.
And so I'm going to use that.
And then the computer can
go and just say, OK, well,
there's some file that
has all those exponents.
And the computer looks up the
numbers and says, for carbon,
you need this; for oxygen,
this; for nitrogen, this.
And so the key idea here is
that these are predefined
sets or AO basis functions.
So somebody already
defined these.
You don't have to make a choice.
Other than choosing the
set, there's not other knobs
that you have to turn.
So you can obviously
see the benefit
of this, which is you
don't have to put down
hundreds and hundreds
of numbers in order
to get the calculation to run.
So that's a big win,
which hopefully you're
remember for the
next 25 minutes.
Because the downside,
then, is that you just
noticed I called my basis
set the Troy basis set, which
would give you absolutely no
idea of what was in that basis
set, just that I
made the basis set.
And then somebody
else might call it
the Cambridge basis set because
they did it in Cambridge.
And somebody else might
number their basis sets.
You know, this is
basis set number 17.
And none of those
things actually
tell you what's actually
in the basis set
and how they designed it.
They just give it a name.
But then that name is-- you have
to know the name in order to be
able to specify the basis set.
And you have to know what--
you have to sort of
memorize, oh, well,
this basis that does this.
This basis set does this.
Or at least remember
where to look up
what those basis sets do.
So for the next
20 minutes or so,
we're going to talk about
some of those things.
And you'll be
annoyed at the fact
that these basis sets have these
funky, weird names and design
principles, I think.
But just remember, I don't
have to put in 100 numbers.
This is the price
you pay for not
having to put in 100 numbers.
So the first thing that
we'll talk about here--
so I'll say that basis sets
are typically grouped by row.
Of course, the basis sets
are going to be different.
So hydrogen's going to need
a different number of basis
functions than carbon.
Argon's going to need a
different number from carbon
or hydrogen just
because they have
different numbers
of valence functions
and different numbers
of core functions.
And I'm also going to
introduce a shorthand.
So first of all, I'll note
that we already have--
so actually, I'll just
introduce the shorthand.
So, say, for nitrogen
and for the basis set
we've talked about so far,
the minimal basis set,
the smallest basis
set I can come up
with for nitrogen
would need to have
the 1s function, the 2s
function, and the 2p function.
I need at least those
functions to just
have places to put all
of my nitrogen electrons.
Now, I'll get
writer's cramp if I
have to write all
of these things out.
So I'm going to develop
a shorthand, which
is when I have 1s
and 2s, I'm just
going to denote that as 2s.
So I'm not indicating that
2s is the last function.
It's Indicating that
there are two of them.
So I have two s-type
functions, one
that's sort of core like and
one that's sort of valence like.
But there's two of them.
And then I have one
p-like function.
So I'll put 1p So
that's just telling me
how many of each of
these things I have.
So again, this is the
number of s-type functions.
This is the number
of p-type function.
And so then we
can go, and we can
talk about the one basis
set we've dealt with so far,
which is the minimal basis set.
So for hydrogen and
helium, it's just
going to be that 1s
function on each of those.
And then when I go
down to the next row,
it looks just like
nitrogen. They all
are going to need in an s
core function and an s valence
function and a p
valence function.
So there'll be 2s, 1p-like.
And then I go down one more
row for sodium through argon,
and I'll need
another s function.
So it'll be total of
three s-type functions.
And then I need two sets of
p, a core p and a valence p.
So there's 2p.
So that's the minimal basis.
That's the smallest basis that I
could conceive of for any atom.
And then we're going
to have various ways
of trying to make these things
more elaborate, more broke.
And the most common
way to do this
is to note that, well, when
I bring atoms together,
it's the valence functions
that actually either contract
or expand in order to describe
the electrons moving around.
The core functions don't
really change very much.
And so in order to give the
valence functions flexibility
to change, it makes sense to
add more valence-like functions.
So if the valence
was s, it makes sense
to add another s function.
Or if the valence
was p, it makes sense
to add another p function.
And so we get a name here, this
concept, which is minimal basis
is what's known as a single zeta
basis set because it has just
one set of valence functions.
It might seem like would
make better sense to call it
a single valence basis set.
But history made a
different choice.
It said that it's zeta.
I don't know why they chose
the name zeta, but they did.
So the zeta just
means that there's
one set of valence functions.
And then you can think
about making a double zeta.
So you'd take every
valence function,
just add another
valence function
that has a different
exponent so it
would allow more flexibility.
So that'll be a Double
Zeta basis set, DZ.
So for hydrogen and
helium, it's all valence.
So we'd just get
two s functions.
For things in the same
row as lithium and neon,
the valence functions
are in s and a p.
And so when we
double those, we're
going to add another
s-type function
and another p-type function.
So we would go 3s
2p here because we'd
add one s function
and one p function.
And then for sodium through
argon, we would have 4s 3p.
And then we could go on
and talk about, oh, well,
what about a triple zeta?
So triple zeta would be
3s for hydrogen helium.
And then we add an s and
a p for the next row.
So it's 4s 3p.
And then we add s and p for
this, and we end up with 5s 4p.
And so again, the idea
here is that for carbon, we
might have 1s that's the core.
And then we'd have 2s and 2p as
the first valence and then 3p.
And these would
respectively be--
so the single zeta or--
and then you include
the next cell.
And it becomes-- or
sorry, single zeta
would be all of this, sorry.
Oh, it's the core.
And then you could
say, all right, well,
but then I include another set.
And this gives me a
double zeta basis set.
And then I could
include another set,
which would give me a triple
zeta kind of basis set.
Then you can go
on and on and on.
So you could just make a
quadruple zeta and quintuple
zeta basis set.
And then this is where
the names get annoying.
So the name of the most common
minimal basis set is STO-3G.
And that stands for Slater-Type
Orbitals 3 Gaussians,
just in case you're
wondering why it's STO-3G.
And then for the
double zeta basis set,
there are ones that
are called 3-21G,
6-31G, another one that
is somewhat confusingly
just called DZ, Double
Zeta, as if there
was only one such basis set.
And then for a triple zeta,
you can do 6-311G triple zeta
valence.
And there are others.
So there are other
abbreviations out there as well.
But that's how you would
do these kinds of-- how you
change the zeta, the valence.
So questions about those?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is
there [INAUDIBLE]
in the example you're including
as your additional zetas,
like 3s 3p 4s.
But would there be an
advantage to including
things that weren't atomic
orbital-like things?
TROY VAN VOORHIS: Yes.
So there are
occasionally times where
people include basic
functions that don't
look like atomic orbitals.
So the most common one is to
make bond-centered functions.
Like say, I want a bond
here, and you could
put basis functions there.
There's a couple of reasons
that becomes undesirable.
One is that, then, you can't
use a standard basis set
because basis sets have to be
sort of anchored to the atoms.
That's how we catalog them.
If you say, oh, I'm going to put
one in the middle of the bond,
you say, well, it would
depend on both atoms involved
in the bond and how long the
bond was and things like that.
So that's a little
bit undesirable.
The other one is that unless
you pin that bond function down
to a particular position, if
you let the center of that bond
function move, there's actually
numerical instability that
happens when two Gaussians
come on top of each other.
And that can sometimes
cause calculations--
the computer to choke.
So that in practice, we
usually stick to increasing
the atomic basis sets.
Oh, but there is
also one other case.
In physics, they are much
more fond of using solids.
That's sort of one of
the things that chemists
tend to think about
molecules as the example.
Physicists tend to
think about solids.
And in solids,
they're much more fond
of using plane waves
as their basis set.
So they start off
with the free--
instead of starting off
with atoms as the reference,
they start off with free
electrons as their reference.
And then say, oh,
and then we introduce
these potentials which
are perturbations
to the free electrons.
So you get plane waves
as your basis set.
You make linear
combinations of plane waves
instead of atomic functions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
atomic orbitals
do we need [INAUDIBLE]?
TROY VAN VOORHIS: That's
exactly the next--
you've hit on exactly
the next thing,
which is that none of those
include any d functions.
I mean, I can go
up to like 18 zeta,
and I would never
have any d functions.
And on hydrogen and helium,
I can go [INAUDIBLE]..
I wouldn't even have
any p functions.
And certainly there
are situations
where you would want these
higher angular momenta.
One of them is if you're
in an electric field.
So that polarizes electrons
and tends to actually require
slightly higher angular
momenta functions in order
to describe that polarization.
And the other one is for just
the directionality of bonding.
That if you had, like, an
SN2 reaction or something
like this, where temporarily
something was either actually
hypervalent or sort
of hypervalent,
you would need these higher
angular momentum functions
to describe the hypervalency.
And so those are called
polarization functions.
So here polarization
functions are
things that add higher
angular momentum and valence.
So you need this for
things like polarizability,
which is why they're called
polarization functions.
But you also need it for
things like hypervalency.
And so the nomenclature
for polarization functions
is also a bit weird.
But the simplest one is that
you just add the letter P,
so P standing for
Polarization to the basis set.
And then the idea
is that you're just
going to add one
function with that P.
You when you add
the P, that means
you're adding one function that
has one unit higher angular
momentum.
So if P was your highest
angular momentum,
you're going to
add a d function.
And if s was your
highest angular momentum,
you're going to
add a p function.
So for hydrogen
and helium, that's
going to add a P to lithium.
To argon, it's going to add a D.
If you did this also the
transition metal atoms,
you would note the transition
metal atoms have d functions
already.
So the polarization
would add an f function,
just adding one higher
angular momentum.
So then going back to our table
up here, let me use my magic,
copy the double zeta
basis results here-- copy.
There's my double zeta.
Now I'm just going to add
the polarization to this, so
double zeta plus polarization.
Now I add my
polarization functions.
And so for hydrogen
and helium, I'm
going to add one p function
to get a DZP basis set.
Lithium to neon, I'm
going to add 1 d function.
For sodium to argon, I'm
And then I can do the same
thing with triple zeta.
So if I make a TZP basis set,
then I'll add 1p, 1d, and 1d.
And I'll note that you could
also do a TZ 2p basis set.
And then you're
adding-- the 2p just
indicates that I'm adding even
more polarization functions.
So I'm adding two sets of d
functions instead of just one
or two sets of p functions
instead of just one.
And then these
things have names.
So there's a 6-31G star, which
is a very common DZP basis set.
Or there's also that DZ
basis that I mentioned above
has a DZP generalization of it.
Or you could have for the
triple zeta, the TZVP basis,
or the longest basis
set name, 6-311G (d, p).
This is where the annoyance
started to come in.
You're like this is annoying.
But it's less annoying
than the alternative.
So we deal with it.
So questions about that?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 1p--
I'm sorry.
That 1p, they're just like,
we're going add DZ squared.
Or [INAUDIBLE]?
TROY VAN VOORHIS: It's
one set of d functions.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
TROY VAN VOORHIS: Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Why can't we
have a single [INAUDIBLE]??
TROY VAN VOORHIS: Oh, we could.
But, yeah, we could do that.
So part of this has to do with--
and there are a couple of
basis sets that do that.
This mainly represents
the hierarchy
of empirically what people
have found is most important.
So if you just start with a
minimal single zeta basis set,
you say, well, what's the
next most important thing?
Usually almost always
going to double zeta
is more important than the
polarization functions.
So very few people bother making
single zeta plus polarization.
They'll say, OK,
we'll do double zeta.
And then after you
do double zeta, then
maybe you want to
go to polarization.
Or maybe you want to
go to triple zeta,
depending on what you're doing.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TROY VAN VOORHIS:
It would be 1s 1p
for hydrogen, 2s 1d for carbon.
It would just be to add that
extra polarization function
on top of the existing set.
AUDIENCE: And would the
polarization be the--
which AO did that come from?
TROY VAN VOORHIS:
What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: So for hydrogen, would
it be adding the 2p basis or--
TROY VAN VOORHIS: It
would be like adding--
now, so for hydrogen, it
yeah.
For hydrogen, it would
be like the 2p function.
But again, when we
go back, we remember
that we're not actually using
the hydrogenic functions.
We're using Gaussians
to approximate them.
And so all it really means is
that it has the same angular
distribution as a p function.
But the radial part
is whatever the person
who made the basis set
decided to make it.
All right, then I have--
so then when I teach this class,
I often have clicker questions.
So this would have been
the clicker question.
So we'll do it by show of
hands instead of by clicker,
since we're small enough.
So here's a test of
whether we understood--
I can't show-- well, anyway.
So I'll go back
and put things up
in just a second,
if you need them.
But my question is, how many
basis functions will there
be for C60 in a DZP basis set?
I guess should say [INAUDIBLE].
So option A is there'll
be 60 basis functions.
So that would be how many basis
functions per carbon atom?
One.
All right, or 180,
that's three per carbon.
360, that's six per carbon.
840 is-- I can't--
anybody do the math
better than me?
Is that 14?
No.
No way.
Yeah, it's 14.
Yeah, 14-- 14 per carbon.
This is-- huh?
AUDIENCE: 18.
TROY VAN VOORHIS: 18.
And then this is
21, then, right?
Yeah, so we've got,
1, 3, 6, 14, 18, 21
as the number of
basis functions per.
And I'll go back
and throw this up
for those who want the table up.
We didn't write all that down.
So here's our EZP basis set.
Carbon's in this group here.
All right, so then
now I'll go back.
Everybody feel like
they got their answer?
OK.
So by a show of
hands, how many people
think the answer is A, 60?
Nobody, all right.
How about B?
C?
We go most on C, OK.
D?
I don't know, E?
F?
Everybody says C. C is
not the correct answer.
And every year people
miss this question.
So the key thing to get
this right-- and we're
going to re-poll
in a minute here.
But the key thing
to get this right
was actually the
question that you
asked, which is that you
said, when I add a d function,
do I add DZ squared, or
do I-- and I said, no,
you add a set of d
functions, which is how many
functions in d?
5.
All right, so now
we'll go back and look.
All right, but don't feel bad.
Every year, the majority of
people choose that same answer.
So now let's redo our math.
AUDIENCE: I've never
gotten it right.
TROY VAN VOORHIS:
Never gotten it right?
OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
All right, so now
we'll go through.
OK, how many people think A?
How many B?
Nobody's going to say C
because I already told you
that was wrong.
How many people say D?
All right, good,
you're all right.
Yes, the answer is
D. In a DZP basis
there are 14 basis
functions per carbon atom.
Now, you can already
start to see even
for this DZP basis,
which isn't the biggest
basis we've talked
about, for C60,
you've got 840 basis functions.
That's a lot of basis functions.
So that's why we're really
glad that the computer's doing
the work and not us
because 840 integrals--
well, 840 by 840 matrices are
hard to diagonalize by hand.
Doing all those integrals
is really, really a pain.
So then going
beyond those basis--
so those two things are
the key basis set ideas.
I'll just touch on a
couple of other things
before we finish up.
So the first thing
is diffuse functions.
So occasionally,
if you have anion,
so you have an extra
electron, that extra electron
is not very well
described by the valence
because negative electrons tend
to spread out a great deal.
Bob is one of the world
experts in Rydberg states,
which is where these electrons
spread out a really, really
significant amount.
And so these Gaussian
functions that decay quickly
don't describe those well.
And so you have
to add a Gaussian
with a small value of alpha.
And it's mostly
useful for anions.
So you add these in order
to describe anions better.
And the notation here is
either you use the phrase aug
or plus to the basis set.
So if the basis set has the
word aug in front of it,
that means it has some diffuse
functions on it in order
to describe those
weakly bound electrons.
Or the plus indicates it has
some of those functions in it.
And again, those are added
with the same angular
momentum as the valence.
They're not usually polarization
and diffuse at the same time.
And then the final thing is
you can generalize these ideas
to transition metals.
It's a little bit hazy
because a lot of this
is predicated on us knowing what
the valence of the element is.
And for transition metals,
it's like, well, is s
in the valence?
Yeah, probably.
Is p in the valence?
Well, maybe.
I don't know.
D is definitely in the valence.
But depending on what
you think the valence is,
your definition of some of these
things is a little bit fuzzier.
Sometimes you add a p function.
Sometimes you don't when
you go from double zeta
to triples for a
transition metal.
But the overall idea
here is that we're
trying to approach this
particular limit, which
is known as the complete
basis set limit, which
is the result that you
would hypothetically
get with an infinite
number of atomic orbitals.
So you just crank up, include
all the atomic orbital
in the universe.
You would get to an answer
that would be the right answer.
And we're just trying to
asymptotically approach that
by making our basis
sets bigger and bigger
until we run out of steam.
All right, so that's
everything about basis sets.
And tomorrow-- or not
tomorrow, next Monday we
will talk about how
you compute the energy.
All right, Happy Thanksgiving.